serious question large
so someone banged the Emperor yuck hey
Mitch McConnel ask kids ok raise about
20 she was born about 10 years after the
original trilogy let's say her parents
were in their 30s that means she was
getting it on right around the clone
wars what did he at the time is the
bubble opera his third date move did you
have a tragedy of coming home with me
tonight the whole movie premise was
about tracking down Palpatine's planet
what was the plan if the emperor ever I
don't know moved he's got a summer home
in Naboo what all those sis cultists do
and they're not hanging out and they
evil Colosseum do they have an evil
Disneyland galaxy's edge Lourdes Luke's
x-wing smell terrible
I mean right now that we've seen ray
train and Leia train do we all feel
better about them being space wizards I
know I do ray passes life force to kylo
who passes it back to Rey if they did it
fast enough could they just have kept
snowballing life back and forth forever
gross but also like good thing of all
the places in the galaxy why would ray
choose to retire at her dead boyfriend's
grandfather stepdads son's farm she does
like sand
so Poe used to be a drug mule there's no
way they're a billion his anti drug
wedge antilles sold me weed why does poe
hey bones what kind of spice was poe
running did it come out of that worm i'm
psyched about dune come talk about dune
instead han Solo Rey Skywalker does
everyone just get to pick their Star
Wars name all willy-nilly because mine
would be bongo swing chub-o
call me Gary swing job was my
are we supposed to learn anything about
the new characters or should we wait for
their spin-offs on Disney Plus Gianna
and the former soldier coming in 2023
under $4.99 a month can we talk about
the mandalorian instead
what did Lando do to get the whole
galaxy to come help out against
impossible odds did he have sex with the
galaxy Oh Lando you rogue was it awkward
for Lando to get back into the Falcon
after all these years cuz you know like
it has his ex-girlfriend's brain in it
sponsorship now can we talk about
Watchmen instead what was Finn gonna say
to Rey when he thought they were all
gonna die that he's force sensitive that
he loves her that he loves Poe that the
writers forgot to take this anywhere I'm
going with that one then sure doesn't
care about killing stormtroopers now
does he weird choice in a movie that
lets you know they're all kidnapped
orphans they chose to be kidnapped
orphans can we talk about the Great
British Bake Off instead after a
one-on-one with kylo Ren trying to
kamikaze himself on crate and trying to
go down with the Star Destroyer in this
one can we let Finn die then clearly
wants to die just what was the point of
Anakin Skywalker being the chosen one
and bringing balance to the force if the
Emperor survived that means we got six
movies about a guy who almost did a
thing should we be mad that Star Wars
didn't live up to our expectations or
happy that we finally grew out of Star
Wars hmm we're free to complain about
other Disney products okay - we got a
medal fine but what is that metal for is
it retroactive back to the Battle of
Yavin is it for what just happened is
Maz Kanata on the internet reading that
too we should have gotten a medal
it's a participation award a and who's
Maz Kanata to give Chewie a medal anyway
does she have metal awarding powers who
is Maz Kanata why was she in these
trilogies what's going on I don't
understand any of the
a good question for another time can we
talk about cats I have a lot of question
it's about cats after this and Game of
Thrones should we just skip the endings
of things for a while
you